be okay okay too loud you can get up
down okay well that was a very nice
introduction I appreciate being here
it's always a privilege to speak before
for you guys because you guys are always
sort of the best sort of critics and
best in the best position perhaps to
evaluate the strengths and weaknesses of
this kind of work and in all fairness I
think good disclaimer is that this is
truly sort of fresh off the presses work
so we're still kind of working through
the data and I'll be actually really
interested in getting your feedback
today so if everything works out
properly I'll won't talk nearly as much
as I usually do and try to get you guys
talking a little bit more as a brief
introduction as bill said I've been
working at the VA I've been at the VA
since 2000 and I've been in their
Department of informatics and it's gone
through a number of different iterations
of the years but currently it's been
rebranded the Northwest innovation
center and for those of you that have
been over there I'm thrilled and for
those of you that haven't always welcome
people to come over there because we do
a lot of operational and applied
informatics so it's a it's an
interesting complement to the types of
work that you see over here and within
that department we actually have been
funded by the VA's National Center of
patient safety since two thousand eight
nine and the National Center for patient
safety fund these patient safety center
of inquiries are called Pesky's for
short which that's really rather
unfortunate title and unlike a lot of
traditional research grants where you're
really trying to build on a foundational
knowledge this is more intended be more
of a research and develop more of a
development and implementation kind of
grant so strictly speaking we r we r
charged with the responsibility of
designing evaluating and disseminating
tools that support an important patient
safety challenge by setting the
organization in our particular case
there's a number of PSC eyes but in our
particular case it's medication
reconciliation and arguably we could do
it a whole lot better at the VA and
probably nationwide
so the objectives for today I'm going to
be talking about a little bit about the
RCT but it requires a bit of a setup
otherwise it tends to be a little dry
and so first what I want to do is these
are the objectives I want to cover today
I want to talk about why I think
reconciliation was a worthy focus of a
lot of my career research activities
over the last several years and then I'm
going to show how we try to intersect a
human factors approach in a human
computer interaction perspective on how
we were going to do medication
reconciliation which I think
distinguishes that success is apart from
a lot of the other metric research
activities I see out there in the United
States and many of them are very very
good and then i'm going to introduce the
technology that we had actually designed
here in portland and then move into the
development evaluation lifecycle or at
least that's the way I like to think of
any sort of new technology is that you
have to go through this evolution or
stages of the evaluative process that
starts out from a proof of concept all
the way through to whether or not it
improves health care outcomes and each
step along the way with the
understanding that so often times the
technology in itself is actually quite
good but the implementation is poor or
not well tuned to the environment and
that that actually is where you start to
see problems that you need to tune or
fix okay so let's back up a little bit
show of hands how many of you are our
have been are going to be again
clinicians seeing patients okay fair
number the audience okay and how many of
you have actually been hospitalized or
seen in clinic and your providers asked
about your medication list hopefully
everybody okay all right so at the VA if
you have it worked at the VA or you're
not a veteran this is how it kind of
works it's a little bit like Kaiser so
it's a closed healthcare organization so
we manage the entire medication
distribution supply chain we have the
medications so what happens is you come
in ICU i'm going to write an order for
the medication in the electronic record
then that prescription and there's time
stamp on that that prescription then
goes to a pharmacist pharmacist internal
to my system and they review it and then
they actually finish the order
in our database and then what they do is
they either if the patient's right there
they'll actually dispense it out of our
local dispensary and if they're say out
there in the wild then they will kick
out that prescription to a regional
distribution center as seemed obvious or
a centralized male outpatient pharmacy
and they imagine if you will I've
actually been to one of these there was
one I actually went to in Tucson imagine
something the size of a Super Walmart
floor to ceiling and as just as far as
as far as you can see just racks going
like two three stories high of just
drugs tons of drugs and these conveyor
belts all over the place that are
shuttling drugs all over and they get
they get that one in Tucson for example
they're doing medication dispensation
from all over the west coast including
guam and hawaii and so they're getting
this in every single medication comes
off the conveyor belt and then it has to
be reviewed by a pharmacist or a pharm
tech they have to open it up look at it
confirm it against a picture close it up
verify the address and send it out in
the time stamp that so that you actually
have a time stamp all the way until the
time that the patient gets it so the
only thing you don't have electronically
is when the patient actually stuffs into
their mouth so with that in mind
theoretically since I have all the
information the supply chain I should
know what patients getting so here's the
question that's the question that's fun
to ask what proportion how often do you
think the medication list I see and cprs
when I go and see a patient how often is
that an accurate reflection of what's
the patient's taking this is fun part
throughout any number I'm saying what
percentage of the time no ringers by the
way no ringers what percentage of the
time knowing everything I just told you
about the medication distribution of
supply chain we manage everything what
proportion of the time can I sit sit
look at the chart go yeah well I
actually saw when it was mailed to this
patient this patients been seen
relatively recently so what protected at
the time can I say this is what the
patients taking and I'll even throw in a
bonus which is I attend on rounds with
residents and the most common thing the
residence tell me is we
review the medalist of the patient the
patient says he's taking it as written
it's the most common thing they tell me
so how often is that true we actually
know this what percentage of the time
anything forty percent okay seventy-five
percent tempers you guys are all over
all over the mat okay so you guys are
saying somewhere between ten percent and
seventy-five percent everybody wanted to
give go lower or higher lower all right
okay cool exciting so this study was
actually done by a friend of ours at
iowa city VA yeah awesome right so it
turns out that when they actually looked
at the ambulatory medalist and then
brought the patient in for a gold
standard or whatever you are called
let's call it a reference standard
because you're not really going to know
unless you're doing observed pill
consumption it was five point three
percent of the time so we actually
repeated that work here and for our as
for our RCT and I think we were
somewhere around what Kasich's to three
percent two percent about three percent
two percent of the time okay so this is
really important I wanted to set this up
because I told you residents tell me all
the time they're taking it as written
and if you if you believe in many sort
of statistics the probability that's
true is exceedingly low so you can use
you can operate off a heuristic and go
how off is a patient going to take the
lids can take the medicine in the chart
none never ever so every time I see it
written in the chart that they just drop
in the Med list I know you don't have a
good history that's the heuristic you
know sometimes it's true but in general
it's not and what's more we also know
that we're looking at somewhere in the
neighborhood 22 for discrepancies for
any clinical encounter and I've seen as
high as eight so it really begs the
question first of all what do we need to
do in order to try to improve our
diagnostic discrepancy for diagnostic
capability to detect discrepancies and
the second thing it begs the question is
does it matter because if we nobody's
been doing up until now and patients
have been dropping dead like like like
the apocalypse did it did it make any
difference and this has actually been
brought up to me before us
does it really matter so does it really
matter is a really interesting question
we have a colleague of ours Kenneth book
bar who works he's an infirmity shin he
works at the Bronx VA knees at the he's
at Mount Sinai and he actually doesn't
save research we do and arguably maybe
even better he's a phenomenal a
physician researcher and he actually
tried to figure out what's the
association between the likelihood that
you have a discrepancy and a downstream
clinical event and what we're trying to
do here is build a case that all this
effort that we're going to put into this
makes any some sort of difference ok so
what he found is that he looked at
patients that were discharged from a
Bronx VA to a nursing home where they
actually could track all the medications
even several months out because the
nursing home was actually had their
dispensary in house and he could figure
out how many the discrepant how many
discrepancies there were how many of
them are unintentional and he could look
down stream ago how many of them
actually translate into a clinical event
and it was actually pretty low now there
were a lot of discrepancies that were
intentional for obvious reasons of a
patient's heart failure and you're just
in there diuretics but for those
unintentional ones he found that
actually they had a positive predictive
value or our positive predictive
potential for an adverse drug event
that's clinically meaningful they have
to have something a symptom a bump in
there creating something that with that
change their outcome in an adverse way
but they found actually the positive
predictive value was actually quite low
somewhere about point zero zero three
okay all right and then just for just
for good measure there was actually
another study that was published by
Klaus all with the bates group in
Bates's arguably one of the they've
really put down some of the most seminal
work and the impact of electronic health
records on medication safety and they
found somewhere in there point zero six
so we'll split the difference so let's
say that each medication discrepancy has
a positive predictive value of point
zero zero four or five of having some
clinically meaningful outcome now I
don't know about you but I like thinking
about the way we think about numbers
metacognition and I don't know how to
rationalize point 0045 it just seems so
small as to be negligible and the only
way i can think about it is the
economies of scale
what would that translate to to my
organization would it matter in my
organization so I did the math if you
say that there's on average two
two-and-a-half discrepancies per case
and each one has a positive predictive
value point 0 0 4 5 and at last year at
my organization we did 415,000 out
patient encounters that would translate
to about little over five thousand very
real clinical events preventable adverse
events per year and then if you
calculate on estimate from schneiders
work and there's a number papers or
schneider there's bond there's multivan
Bates has an estimator of what you think
of the cost is of an adverse event so I
try to pick one for an ambulatory set
what's the average cost of an adverse
event or annualize over a year for for
an ad in the outpatient setting and if
you took that and then you multiply that
by what would the number we have you're
looking at a potential savings Oh
annually of about seven million in my
organization that's a number i can start
to get my head around okay so we're
talking like more than a couple plane
crashes of people a year that
potentially could be avoided if we
simply Institute something that would be
a standardized approach to delivering
care okay so what did we try and how
well did it work first I want to talk
about the classic model med recon
because by the way by now in the year
2015 when you talk about when I was
starting to do these talks in 2007-2008
med recon was kind of a hot buzzword it
started to tarnish a little bit there's
a little bit of patina on this because
we've been talking about it for years
and arguably we haven't seen much
substantive improvement the way we do
business we're still doing the exact
same thing we did five years ago hey are
you taking these meds and the patient
goes I think so and you're like well are
you ten your Hydra Karzai is that the
white pill I'm not sure is the white
pill it's this sort of constant exercise
and frustration so maybe part of the
reason we have this exercise and
frustrations that goes back to what is
the model of med rec and I pull this one
from the Joint Commission you can pull
Institute healthcare improvement but
mold multiple different sites
essentially say the same thing they say
it's a four-step process where you
collect a medication list from the
patient you compared to your
organizational documentation you
identify
and resolve discrepancies and then you
furnish the patient with an update list
and you document in your health record
now that sounds really good to promote a
campaign because it's simple
straightforward in its four steps
however I would argue it belies the
inherent complexity of real health care
so for those of you that managed health
care it's anything but normative linear
it easy to anticipate usually it's a
train wreck it's a it's a it's a
controlled mess so how about this we
started with a different approach and I
don't see Dave doing the audience but we
did a lot of this sort of formative work
with dr. door or he said well let's at
least argue that maybe if it doesn't
work like a linear thing but instead
it's a it's a continuous and iterative
cycle of data exchange between you and
the patient and each time is an
opportunity to try to hopefully
incrementally improve the information
you're gathering but at least you're
doing in some sort of patient-centered
way that was the way we envisioned it
and so it actually was Dave that I had
actually coined terms receiver arm and
effector arm because where are you going
to focus your energies do you focus your
energies on how we gather a history or
do you focus your energy that's on how
you resolve discrepancies or both and so
we actually focused upon the collection
of the medication list because we we
still say to this day that the quality
of your medication reconciliation effort
can only be as good as that as the
initial history that you collect when
you meet the patient and then we try to
intersect that idea of okay what can we
do to actually improve our ability as
clinicians to gather data and improve
the patient's ability or at least their
self-efficacy to furnish us with a
decent list because this if there's one
take-home message I want you guys to get
from this is that I'm never necessarily
in daiting the ability of the patient to
give us a medication list I think of it
the same way you know it's been said to
me that you are an expert in what you
eat every day and yet try to actually
tell somebody recount what you have is
the inventory inside your refrigerator
it's virtually impossible to do or
likewise I actually just recently had to
have my car repaired and I'm a
reasonably intelligent person and I've
been studying medicine and statistics
and data for years but when some pizza
when the
annick tells me about my car as far as I
know it works on the shrieking souls of
the Damned so we have to think about how
we can actually improve or augment
people to do their work better and that
includes the patient this is the
approach we took minutes it's borrowed
actually from donabedian and then
revised by pascal carry on out of out of
out of the met at University of
wisconsin-madison and what they said was
is you need to think about any
intervention you design with the intent
to understand the culture the user the
workflow the perceptions of the
individual what they bring to the table
and then try to also consider how that
those those formative elements affect
the cascade of events that result in
your health systems outcomes and try to
try to if you consider in those terms
you're better positioned actually to
predict which variables you can actually
augment or manipulate in order to get
the outcomes of interest so let's take a
look at our technology and why we
thought we were going slightly more
human factors taking a slightly more
human factors approach so we came up
with as I think many of you seen this
before we came up with this device
called a fit the automated patient
history in tape device and the premise
was actually pretty straightforward we
wanted to collect medication history and
we imagined this mashup between the
types of technologies that you see in
the private sector and what we do in
healthcare and healthcare we have the
electronic information or record but in
the private sector you can go to Home
Depot you can purchase things by
yourself you can go to the airport you
can check in for your flight you can you
can upgrade your leg room you can buy
additional oxygen for the fuselage
whatever you need to make your flying
experience more entertaining or
comfortable so we thought of the same
thing here what if we actually
introduced these same kinds of
technologies in a healthcare setting and
actually increase the ability of the
patient actually furnish us with the
quality list so four things really were
the word especially there were four
innovative ideas that we tried to
incorporate into this that thought about
workflow in patients number one the
patient normally sitting out in the
waiting room blacking out teeth in the
People magazine pictures why don't we
have them doing something productive
let's have them look at their
medications
so we're trying to use the the effective
encounter time we're trying to use the
encounter time more effectively to by
doing it we're actually going to furnish
them with all of the list that we have
through all of our databases so that's
actually pretty hard to do when you're
talking about 157 some odd distributed
databases within our enterprise that
don't communicate particularly well so
we're going to gather that automatically
physicians can't do that particularly
quickly they can do it but just not
quickly then we're going to show them
images of the pills so if the patient
goes I'm not sure if I'm taking dokie
satyrs at the reddish kind of one like
this one you can say yeah yeah that's
the one and then what we do is we
actually capture that and automatically
put it into the health record so it's
all automated don't have to type any
keystrokes so hopefully it's going to
actually gift-wrap or package for the
clinician the information they need now
this sounds great on paper but the Pratt
but the question was is could we do this
in a proof-of-concept setting could we
actually implement it in a real-world
setting and was actually going to make
any sort of difference in terms of how
we how we manage our patient population
and if you guys haven't seen this I
really like this kind of approach this
is shamelessly borrowed from from
Friedman and this is he initially called
this the tower of achievement so Charles
Friedman's called the tower achievement
what he was trying to do was in a very
brief sort of opinion piece and jamiat
but it really resonated for me because
the idea was is that any informatics
innovation goes through an evaluation
lifecycle now ultimately we don't build
these widgets just to make ourselves
feel happy we think we hope that we're
leaving our genetic imprint on a health
care system that we're improving the
outcomes of our patients so how do we
know that though well you start with the
proof of theorem the theory should be
sound based upon prior evidence and then
you go through development and you get a
proof of concept and then you test it in
a clinic setting and you say could
people even use it or did it blow up and
then we go through the deployment so
what is it and I try to drawn from
people like tried to try to pull in from
like two views diffusion like the
diffusion of innovation theory like what
types of variables influence people's
perceptions or davis's technology
adoption model what influences their
perceptions of a technology and what's
the probability that they're going to
use them
effectively because that's important to
know whether or not it was actually used
in a skillful and consistent way and
then we look at things like our quality
indicators are key quality indicators or
our outcomes of interest and so that's
what I want to sort of frame it for you
because that's what we're doing here
moving to the ultimate which is an RCT
which is actually looking at not the
outcomes but the surrogates for outcomes
discrepancy detection and high-risk
discrepancies in particular so we
started and by the way as you go through
that there's always going to be critics
and that's appropriate so we did have
many critics in the first criticism that
we heard was patients couldn't possibly
do this and we did exit interviews with
many of our patients and we found that
in general patients could in fact go
through a series of web control of like
buttons look at their medications and
say yes I'm taking no I'm not taking our
at the very least i don't know and i
don't know as an opportunity to have a
conversation what we also found though
and what i think is important about the
sudden i want to draw your attention to
is we put in a production but with no
expectations of use we didn't actually
lever it levy any sort of you must use
this or this must be the standardized
workflow process we let it happen
naturally and in the ecosystem and we
found that in primary care they were
only using about fifty-five percent of
the time in fact more often than not we
were fighting that if you actually try
to engage a clerk in the process the
clerk would go don't worry about that
computer i'll just come check you in so
we had a culture that wasn't really
incentivizing rewarding or reinforcing
the utilization of the technology is it
because the technology's bad or is it
because something about the way we
actually tried to integrate it and
that's what we were trying to find out
so first we started to look at we did
some cross-sectional studies one maybe
we're not getting any information maybe
the information stopped by municipal so
we tried this we started with the most
complex clinic we could think of we
started with a chemotherapy infusion the
reason why
I wanted to find its location we've had
complex patients multiple comorbidities
ton of medications I mean it's any
wonder that there's the sheer volume and
medications they're taking didn't
interact in such way that his patients
glowed when they left the room and then
we made sure that they were actually
being seen in multiple VA facilities so
we were actually the tertiary care with
pearl facility so I want to insert as
many variables as possible that i know
tend to undermine a clinicians ability
to gather medication lists and this is
what we found we found that when we
actually did have them use this
technology and then we went back and we
reviewed the records in a
cross-sectional way we are finding that
indeed we were finding quite a high
number of discrepancies something on the
order of about three to four
discrepancies per case about four and
for those people that said well they're
not the important ones or the kohli so
the multivitamin yeah there's tons of
those but we also found some pretty
critical ones in fact this one I always
like to bring back because to this day I
find it's a useful thing when I'm
telling my colleagues administrators
mid-level managers why do it well that
point zero three are the three
potentially lethal discrepancies those
were all actually anticoagulants so I
actually saw a patient that was he had a
malignancy he had metastatic disease to
the brain he had actually been
supposedly bridge for a procedure and he
would normally on warfarin for afib and
they bridged him to lovenox but they
didn't manage to communicate effectively
to bridge him off and he was lost to
follow-up so this was the gentleman that
had metastatic malignancy in the brain
was taking two full dose anticoagulants
which even if you're not in medicine you
can imagine two full dose anticoagulants
inadvertently in a person that has a
propensity to bleed in the brain sounds
like a really bad thing that really is
so we knew that we were actually finding
real information here that would
actually improve the quality of care
delivery but
I was still sort of struggling with why
were we not able to get primary care
providers to use it specialty care it
some medical subspecialties were
actually doing the best nephrology for
example was doing very very well ID
clinic for example was also doing pretty
well but our primary care clinics not so
much and so that's when we decided well
before we move much farther we need to
understand what are the barriers it
perceived or real and this might inform
the kinds of research we do from this
point forward so we we set up a survey
where we surveyed all of the primary
care providers and residents in the
ambulatory clinics and what we want to
know is we want to ask them about how
what was their perception of their
environment of care what was their
perception of med recon was a perception
of the tool that we were giving them and
then how frequently they used it and how
skillfully we used it and this is all
the reason I have the slide appears
again this is a just briefly introducing
the idea that we wanted to try to use
literature to inform how we ask this
question so that we would move closer
towards trying to better tune our
application depending upon what we found
and there's so many things that in
theory should influence our perceptions
or a utilization of tool your workflow
usability the usefulness of the product
and so what we did is we we went back
and we looked at Davis's at technology
adoption model which is still actually
one of the most ubiquitous models both
inside and outside of healthcare but we
looked at other ones as well a number of
these added variables Tam's as well as
the fit model that was produced by M
worth and we started this and she
synthesize it with a colleague of ours
and new your new jersey we started
synthesized into a model what we call
the the effective technology we use
model because what we want to know is
which variables a small parsimonious
list of variables which ones are most
likely to actually correlate with your
perceptions of the technology and the
probability of consistent use and we
also wanted to know not just consistency
if uses web which people usually ask us
how often you use it what we want to
know how you use metric on tools are you
using it just to update your records are
using it to have a conversation with the
patient or are using it
engage other team members in some sort
of reconciliation event like say a
pharmacist and and I'm this is just an
excerpt but this is what we started
learning we started learn that that
clinicians did in general on average
agree that they thought that the the
tool was useful and improve their
efficiency but we also found something
very interesting which is that a lot of
the clinicians felt that they were
ill-prepared or did not have the
resources necessary to be particularly
effective in the reconciliation efforts
so it's a it's kind of like what you
always sort of expected clinicians are
busy they want to do the right thing but
often times and they have a general
perception of what the right thing looks
like but when you ask them how you
operationalize in a care setting they
don't have time the patient doesn't know
what's going on they don't have the
resources they're backed up they don't
have the right they don't have their
they're backed up on their treatment
rooms they don't have enough room they
don't have enough nursing support
systems or pharmacy support systems and
that was kind of what we found here so
we found it improved reconciliation and
it seemed to be better than past systems
but clinic and clinical self-efficacy
was poor but we also heard something
else which is a lot of the clinicians
felt that it took a lot of mental effort
and they weren't certain how accurate
the information was in comparison to say
a usual care and energy and that was one
of the things that I'd heard a lot was I
I don't mind that you have a technology
out there but it couldn't possibly be
good as my interview my interview is far
superior I heard that in the
perioperative clinic from a couple of
clinicians I really respect and I think
they probably take it to excellent
excellent interviews so but we were
already a point where we're starting
actually say turn this into a national
product and we really realized that if
we're going to start turning this into a
national model we have a huge
responsibility to try to answer that
question for our colleagues how accurate
is it what are the diagnostic
characteristics so we are in fact moving
to a national platform the VA has
adopted this model and is starting to
re-engineer it for for a enterprise-wide
deployment and it's going to look a
little different they're actually going
to connect to our corporate data
warehouse to gather information
from multiple installations as I said
before we have 157 facilities 157
instances of the health record so they
are actually going to wear that all that
data is archived normalized in Austin
they're going to pull that information
match it up to pill images that are
stored or procured by our seam ops which
I told you about earlier these these
large dispensary warehouses so that we
have a reference point when the patient
checks in and these are actual
screenshots of what the device is going
to look like we just usability tested an
iteration of it several weeks ago and
we're writing up a report on this we
actually work with a group out of
university of british columbia victoria
that Audrey kirschner egg trying to
evaluate the human factors perspective
and how this how patients either are
able to use it or struggle with this
technology so now let's look at the
diagnostic performance so we've talked a
little bit about what we developed we
talked about deployment and some of the
challenges associated with deployment a
lot of the cultural or perceptors
perceptual based in terms of Y
clinicians where we're not using it and
we start to look at whether or not it's
actually able to detect discrepancies
which is a key quality indicator but we
didn't really have a sense of our
diagnostic performance and something and
comparing it to something that we feel
is a reasonable standard a gold standard
okay so we started again with the model
what are we really trying to do here so
imagine if you will that we're going to
have two axes on the x-axis resources so
if I put in just a little bit of
resources versus enormous amount of
resources and I want to think about how
much accuracy what what return can I get
on my investment and we're going to
assume along the top the top is truth
truth is absolute perfect this is what
the patient does on any given day and we
will back at the literature and we said
where do we think we exist using
different kinds of resources on this
hypothetical topology
so we know an already the medical record
I already told you that three to five
percent just look at the medical record
and say is that what I'm taking the
patient goes yeah I'm taking whatever is
written in the chart that's it I'm
taking anniversary chard I'm taking
whatever's in there I think so my wife
fills my pill box anything if you just
accept that we think you're probably
about five percent of the time right we
know from patient interviews from
studies of patient interviews by
Badowski and some other groups that were
largely pharmacist we know that we can
get pretty good but we know it's not
perfect because we also know that when
they compared to things like pill
reviews they're not as good as a pill
review if you have all the medications
in front of you and they're also not
truth because we also know that if you
do home health visits often times you'll
find other medications that the patient
and report to you stockpiles over the
counters herbals whatever back wanna
whatever whatever you can possibly
imagine we found in their homes so we
think and we're what we're trying to
figure out is where does the patient
review fit into that I don't really
believe that having the patient's it
with a technology in the waiting room is
really better than a patient than a
structured patient interview with the
clinician but certainly better than
simply looking at the chart but where
this was our hypothesis we think that a
patient if a patient reviews list it's
pretty good and if we can do it an
automated or systematized way that would
be a substantial improvement we also
think that by using the technology we
could incremental improve upon that why
because we're getting more data and
we're also getting and we're also
furnishing the patient with images so
the patient is that going I think so is
that the white one is that the yellow
one we can show it to it and we set up
our study like a diagnostic study so we
said we want to look at what the pot
what we want to look at the sensitivity
and specificity of our diagnostic
instruments so now we're thinking about
this teeth this kiosk technology a
diagnosis tool and we're going to say
that looking for disease quote unquote
as the discrepancy very simple premise
and we actually we're going to look at
two arms we wanted to look at how do we
do if we need a paper so just any
systematized process and then how much
does it incrementally improve if we do
it on the computer with the with the
addition of multimedia and this was how
we designed the study and this is
actually something that we published
with with Dave door so what we did was
we said okay we're going to take a group
of patients and all these patients are
going to have to have at least they're
going to have to have at least a handful
of medications and they have to have at
least one visit why visit well because
we need to make sure that we actually
have some sort of medication list as a
comparator and then we're going to
randomize them to one of two arms we're
going to either put them in a
paper-based review where they sit down
with the sheet of paper that's generated
from this canonical list so we're going
to put together a list of medications
for multiple VA's including some recent
expired because we knew from prior
literature the patients are often taking
expires and discontinues and we're going
to compare it to that they sat down with
the computer terminal then we're going
to bring them into a room and we're
going to sit them down with the
clinician they have to bring all their
pills with them and the clinician is
going to conduct a structured interview
using a standard set of questions in a
standard order and the patient has to
have all their medications with now
here's the weird thing then we had to do
a triangulation is anybody can anybody
think about why because we ended up very
quickly we piloted this and within one
or two and cast it was very quick right
within just a handful of patients just
piloting this we had a problem something
went wrong and we had to do a
triangulation so what do you think that
was yeah
human interface with the tech go on so
what you think what do you mean Kiki's
that uses human interface with the
technology
okay okay so one possibility i heard is
that well maybe we had to add another
layer because because there was
something wrong somehow when we started
interviewing the patient we realized
that things blew up with the technology
anything else this actually goes back to
I'll tell you part of the problem was is
we just didn't see coming but part of
this goes back to something that you're
not supposed to violate when you do a
random like because randomized control
trial
that's true we we definitely did but I
still wouldn't necessarily need to
triangulate would I I mean I have a gold
standard the histories my gold standard
why have to go beyond
interesting so the patients actually
they were not blinded so it's a
single-blind to study I was actually one
of the people that had to do the
interviews along with several other
classrooms I couldn't tell so what would
happen is the patient when I'll tell you
patient would come into the room and I
do an interview but here's the problem
now I have a safety issue because
whatever they said before would
potentially get to the record and
whatever I found could potentially be
different than what they said so I had
to resolve those and pass them on to a
clinician this wasn't a real clinic and
what did we find we found that sometimes
my interview wasn't as good as the paper
or the eighth or the eighth it by the
way I didn't know what they were doing
they come in and I interview them and
then I'd have to turn over the sheet of
paper because we took all of their
answers and we convert them to a paper
report so I couldn't figure out which
patient did which are I just knew their
answers that's all I knew but every time
I get them I look at the answers I go
these answers this is different than
when I just interviewed so let's go over
it again and what with patients say they
go no no no that's what I really meant
it you've met what you what you reported
before I talk to you yeah you just
didn't understand me dr. less right so
suddenly our gold standard was nothing
more than ten because what I'm starting
to find is any information would
actually improve the quality of the
history and when I confirm this with a
patient when I'd actually check the
results i found that oftentimes the
interview wasn't that great either so we
were actually had we had to we had
another an additional comparator I had
another I had an interview but there
wasn't a gold standard so we decided and
this is a problem because now your gold
standard if I if I actually go with the
triangulation and figure out what
they're really taking after three or
four sources of information the problem
with the triangulation is you've just
violated one of the standard principles
of doing an RCT your gold standard
should not be influenced by the results
of the test but here we had a conundrum
so we had used both an unusual situation
that you kind of only really seen an
informatics type thing I haven't really
seen this too often other kinds of
diagnostic tests where everything
essentially got flipped backwards where
we had to go okay we're going to compare
each arm to our medication history we
know our medication history is no longer
goaltenders just an interview nothing
more and then we're going to compare it
to our reference dinner but we're going
to keep both in the equation because we
want to see how we compared to the
reference standard and we want to see
how we compare the interview recognizing
reference standard is actually
influenced by our interventions that was
a toughy so this is actually how we
operationalize this concept we were
going to see how often the XYZ these are
discordant so we were going to see how
often our technology actually found
discord information compared to an HR
composites so how often do we get
discrepancies basically and we also want
to see how often each arm was concourt
nor discordant with both the interview
and the reference standard and if
everything's working out the wish we
hoped it would if you just sort of
picture in your head you're going to
find a whole bunch of discrepancies so
this arms going to start moving away
from computer and closer to truth and if
we're really lucky these two arms are
going to move that direction at it just
at a different rate that was the idea so
this was our enrollment we powered it we
powered it where we needed about 200
patients and we wanted a power at the
patient level we didn't power it at the
discrepancy level of the medication
level because we couldn't actually make
any assumptions about independence each
patient each did each air each
medication or each error actually is
nested in the eye in the concept of the
patient so this is at the level of the
patient 600 sweet contacted we had 614
appointments that we that we had a pool
to work from we were able to consent to
20 and we actually got 209 that made it
all the way through the completion will
be able to look at their data so
starting with the descriptive statistics
what did we find so not surprisingly our
veterans are of a slightly older
population than probably you would
expect probably in a community practice
the average age is six ninety-five
percent of the moment male and they had
a high number of chronic medical element
so comorbidities 5.5 on average we're
going to copd CHF coronary disease so
forth you'll notice i think the areas
that i bolded which I think are hard to
sort of distinguish until I explain it
we looked at the number of medications
in the number of active prescriptions
medications for us also meant over the
counters or medications that were
expired but the patient still taking so
we actually looked at a lot more total
medications than active prescriptions
the patient was carrying on their
medication lists but the average number
of medications the patient carry on
their list was 11.5 arguably quite a bit
higher than some of the studies that
you'll see published on that recon where
it usually hovers around four or five
arguably when do you think things start
to get unsafe for patient how many
medications do you need to start
exponentially increasing the number of
potential errors or drug drug
interactions anybody know somebody said
57 yeah the number that's been published
at least is four so that gives you an
idea of the complexity or the risk
burden that we're looking at with a
veteran population then we actually
looked at the discrepancies so we looked
at 3,500 medications and we picked up 14
hundred some-odd discrepancies overall
not great and by discrepancies again I
mean compared to our our our usual care
which is the health record system and
then when you break it into the two
groups now I will tell you that this
stuff is really really fresh so I'm very
much interested in your feedback we
literally have gotten we really
literally receive this from our
statistician just within past few weeks
and it's not terribly surprising but a
little bit alarming in that we expected
to see a lot of discrepancies but maybe
not quite this proportion we did expect
to see a lot of medium and high risk
discrepancies now we actually coded all
these based upon previous published
literature and by if you have it to be a
high risk or lethal risk lethal risk you
really have to be something like on an
anticonvulsant and anticoagulant or or
an oncology agent and
typically a chemotherapeutic arcology
agent and we actually found a not
insignificant number of those a lot of
problems that they say coumadin for
example and then high risk it had to be
a drug to make it into the high risk
category how to be a drug that's
managing one of your chronic conditions
of that if there was a discrepancy we
envision that there would be a potential
problem in terms of their their their
illness management like a beta blocker
for some way on heart disease our
diuretic on for somebody that's on
that's got to heart failure and again we
saw a relatively high proportion of
high-risk not a high proportion of
lethal risk but certainly not
insignificant either oh the other thing
I want to draw your attention to is the
system and patient you know when I was
doing this work I was working with
hospitals and some of the hospital said
to me you know I they were very
sympathetically said I really appreciate
what you're doing Blake and I'm glad
that you're making these efforts to try
to improve our ability to gather
information I don't I don't really think
it matters because I do that I've done
this for 10 years I remember one fair
very clearly one consciousness saying
Blake I've done this for 10 years and it
just doesn't matter no matter how hard
you work the patients just can't keep it
straight it just doesn't matter and
obviously I think it does matter but but
I understand on sympathetic to the point
that you start to get this sense of
frustration that you're working with
somebody that doesn't understand
medications the way you do and what you
know what can you do if essentially you
release that patient back out into the
wild let the doves fly what are you
going to do and so that's why we want to
look at well how often in time do we
think that the root cause of this
discrepancy would be based on something
we did with our documentation either we
didn't update the documentation or we
didn't listen to patient or we left
something hanging out there that
shouldn't have been hanging out there
and we found actually close to fifty
percent of time I mean it's almost half
and half that we're partially to blame
in our healthcare organizations
record-keeping strategies and I thought
that was important because even if you
could change patients at all which I
don't think it's a matter of changing
them or not changing it was a matter of
being patient centered but even if you
held to that philosophy there's so much
that we can do on our side of the
equation
disagreement now we're still cooking
these numbers meaning this this stuff
we're still going to be looking at it
for the next several months and this is
just the preliminary data spoiler alerts
so far I'm not saying that there's
dramatic improvements in our technology
but looking at the EHR versus the
instrument I want to draw your attention
really to the first one we're seeing
that we're finding discrepancies in in
both arms our paper or the technology
and it doesn't appear to me that we're
seeing more discrepancies or detecting
more accurate discrepancies using
technology a little bit of a little bit
of a letdown but I still think this is
very interesting for a number of reasons
well against it and remember what I said
earlier about this was all about trying
to figure out what's the diagnostic
potential and so all just grant went
right back to grounds right back to this
conversation I have that clinician years
ago is going nothing you do is as good
as my interview there's nothing you can
do your technology it's cute it's
gimmicky but it's just not as good as
what I do and I always thought that was
so interesting how good is it how good
is this is the diagnostic performance so
using the standard two-by-two table that
you guys have all seen here's paper the
sensitivity and specificity compared to
our reference standard i use the
triangulation one as our reference
standard you could say i should have
used the interview but i decided to go
with what I think is the closest
approximation of truth about 90%
sensitivity specificity not bad not bad
here's the technology
numbers didn't shift much not the same
that may be it sensitivity is actually
worse now arguably I don't think this is
anime statistically significant
difference but still a little bit
surprising for all the technology could
we've just done paper and actually we
just did paper reliably that's pretty
good I think it's better actually than
what I expected so what's going on here
well that remember this slide accuracy
versus resources and this is what I said
I think's going on it's pretty early but
I don't think this is what's going on I
think it's more like this I think still
if you say you're looking at the
medication the medical record going this
what you're taking mr. Jones mr. Joseph
and anyone ever says in there i take
whatever they say in there just check
with my wife I think you're still hosed
I absolutely think your host but what's
interesting is is and we definitely know
that when you do a patient interview and
then you gather more information things
change stuff moves we're not the first
ones to report that but I still think
that at that top end of the curve it's
probably somewhere in that ballpark but
now I know the patient list and
technology seem to be pretty close to
each other almost equal final but better
than I thought maybe within ninety
percent eighty-five ninety five percent
of accuracy enough that you shouldn't be
interviewing a patient no of course not
but perhaps enough that you can start to
recalibrate how you think about
medication discrepancies and better
target where you're going to focus your
energies as a busy overworked under
resourced clinician so this is what
we've actually on a backup so just out
of curiosity because i don't know i mean
i'm making up as I go why do you guys
think the technology didn't work better
okay so one argument is is you're just
getting your getting the same
information you're getting the same
information from the same source you
just did in a slightly different way you
just sat down a different backing track
that's it what else and by the way if I
can ask people to push the buttons and
the microphones in front of them so it
gets picked up by our recording and so
people listening can hear it but the I
mean the real the real intervention is
is the sort of sitting down with the
patient and going through the
medications so you know that that
intervention may be overwhelming any
potential benefit of any kind of
technology that you've added okay okay
so that's certainly plausible where we
really set up a pretty odd Bali usual
care and gold standard I mean our gold
standard is a little more gold than your
typical and our usual care even the
paper we're pulling from a lot of
different resources that you would
normally have in the context of real
care so that's you know it's possible
like like like dr. Hirsch is saying was
the study design we are arguably we try
to set up to be as rigorous as possible
to detect nuanced changes but maybe it
just simply diluted our treatment effect
you had a suggestion it's not your
effectiveness is somehow getting washed
out by kind of a broad application of
what you want to do and I think you kind
of mentioned this that maybe more
directed approach might give you a
little more efficacy somehow there's
some data washing going on just with the
broad population I like limitation I
like it I think these are all very these
are so and I want to hear what you guys
say because these are some of the ideas
that we came up with and none of them
necessarily are correct but one is one
is we were just so darn overwhelmed I
mean when you're talking about patients
with like 1260 I saw page 150 meds 50
meds I mean that's insane I can't
believe this guy's head didn't explode
so is it possible that you just simply
completely overwhelmed their cognitive
faculties I mean that's like asking me
to try to describe how to re and reading
a rebuild an engine and I don't know
anything about a car so maybe that's it
but maybe it's just too many round white
pills celexa looks a lot like aspirin
which looks a lot like you know
alt tablet they all look white round and
scored so maybe images isn't doing it
maybe it's the control design it's like
a couple of you guys said is we just
went we count big and we had a very
unusual set of control versus maybe
maybe it's a lot better than usual care
but our control is hardly what you call
usual care anymore the other thing that
kind of threw it was interesting to me
is we thought about was whether or not
the computer we were actually even
talking about this as recent as the
morning this morning does computers
actually make things worse I thought we
were putting in pictures and pictures
are great but maybe when you set a
person down from the workstation and the
fonts different experience is different
maybe that difference is a confounder
and then this is I put up this graphic
because I thought this was pretty
interesting too is that we all sort of
cat we all believe and there's some
reasonably good data as the port that's
that that's something called the
pictorial superiority event we remember
experiences actually the most if you
experience something it actually tends
to forged better long-term episodic or
semantic memories but in the in lieu of
that showing people pictures or objects
interacting the objects pictures
something visual in general tends to
actually forge better long-term durable
memory but that actually seems to go
down as you go as you get older and it
appears that sometimes the pictorial
superiority effect starts to go away or
converge with other ways we encode
memory as we get older so you maybe even
that's it so in conclusion and hopefully
have a little bit longer than I wanted
to go but in conclusion what I wanted to
share with you is that I'm excited a
little humbled but nonetheless excited
to share with you the very very newest
data that we have on our study which I
think there's some things that i can say
that i think are good we can say that by
intervening in a systematized way we can
dramatically improve our ability
detective discrepancies above what I
frequently see done as an ad hoc process
within my own facility I think by using
technologies in the right way in the
human factors way where we try to
actually optimize the time
that the clinicians have available I
think we can actually augment
human-based performance we're not trying
to replace an interview replacing an
interview is the wrong way ago it's it's
the unified theorem of informatics you
guys all know it still holds true here
high tech and low-tech solutions may be
equal final in fact if i could get
ninety percent accuracy by just sitting
them down with the sheet of paper that's
a great place to start and so i would
actually suggest that for those people
that say that med recon is too much cost
prohibitive can't get done which i hear
all the time start low start lean and
you probably can get a lot of return on
your investment with with a reasonably
small investment I think the investment
is really in the organization and the
culture as much as it is with anything
you do technology wise and you have to
commit to that standardized process it
has to be rewarded reinforced and
barriers to using that process have to
be removed it has to be done I think at
a level higher than one clinician or one
researcher has to be an organizational
commitment a value system and ethos and
then finally I think we're finding an
awful lot of high-risk discrepancies
more than I anticipated and I think more
than we realistically can handle with
our current systems our current effector
aren't as David had called it and I
think if we're going to move in a strata
in its more systematized way to solve
these kinds of problems we also need to
expect that we're going to need to
resource our clinics and our hospitals
accordingly so that we have better self
efficacy the thing that clinicians told
us way back was a problem I'll stop
there and leave these up here since I
know this is going to be posted for
later ash but I do welcome I appreciate
your time I appreciate they'll ask me to
talk it's always a pleasure to prevent
present before you all because you guys
represent really an interesting niche
set of experts and I appreciate your
time and your interest and I would love
to hear any other questions concerns
comments or criticisms you have because
you're coming at the right time i'm also
open to criticisms because it's early
and more work can be done
thank you
that's a great question yeah so and
that's and I think that's an important
point is that we do know that the
patients patients often will not
actually completely disclose information
to you I struggle with this all the time
patients don't want to disappoint me or
they don't want to appear that there
anything less than and thoughtful and
principled in the way they approach
their healthcare and so that was part of
this triangulation exercises if we're
getting something wildly discordant
between what we when they sit in the
room with me I flip over i take the
interview and then I flipped over the
sheet of paper like this looks big
difference let's go back that was our
goal is to try to essentially one look
at where those differences arose from
how and negotiate them within a in a
relatively well I think in a blame free
environment I say relatively because
it's still an interview room we're still
wearing a white coat and that still
imposes a certain hierarchy that can be
problematic I think that's an important
point to make that we try to minimize
that affect whether it went away
completely probably not would there be
another way to do it possibly maybe even
better without a clinician but for this
particular set of circumstances we
really wanted people that had clinical
prescribing capability that's subject
matter expertise other questions yes
did you look at the effect of having
either the paper or the technology
before the interview like as opposed to
just having an interview is there some
potential benefit of having some sort of
you know activity beforehand that helps
jog the memory that's going to affect
how effective your interview I see
interesting so what you're saying is
what if you did at the arms different
ways you said I'm gonna have one
interview and I'm gonna have one primed
interview yeah no we definitely didn't
do that but that's an interesting
theories is the use of because we do
know I think you bring up an important
point which is what we're starting to
see is and again we're not the first
people to show it it's just we're
finding something that seems to be
triangulating with other people's
research which is if you use multiple
channels and multiple ways you seem to
get a more holistic or representative
model of the truth to interviews
back-to-back space by about a half hour
seemed to change your history I love to
do this to residents called historical
drift the crushing chest pain the
morning invariably becomes right lower
quadrant pain by the afternoon that's
how you can disgrace any in turn
immediately but but the thing is is that
it's definitely true with this so I
think you bring up the corn point which
is what did we do through the priming
experience we don't know this obviously
was it set up for that but it would be
an interesting argument to say I think
technology is important I think
technology is even important for a pill
clinic why because I think the priming
may to do something that actually
positions the pharmd the clinical
pharmacist to have a more successful or
robust clinical experience it's a good
point we didn't test for that yes
yeah yeah and that's an excellent point
so this this point about what can we do
to actually asking a patient again to
recall the contents of the refrigerator
when they show up in clinic is seems
dreadfully unfair actually so what could
we do to actually Prime the patient so
that they are in a better position to be
prepped for clinic that that's excellent
point and actually that is something
that we've been helping another group do
so dr. Steven Simon who's actually at
the he's faculty at Harvard and he's the
section chief of general medicine at the
Boston VA is doing the exact same thing
we're doing only he's trying to do it
over the my healthy that web portal so
what would happen if the patient
actually had this same kind of
information on multimedia list of
medications with images but delivered
into their home environment over a
computer I think absolutely anything we
can do now arguably what you've seen
today could say could I have done
something similar with a card or a phone
call maybe does it have to be a web
portal why is that important for one
because it's possible that the
technology also introduces a new
confounder that makes it more
challenging and to the number of
patients in the VA population that we've
actually authenticated for doing that
type of health record through the home
is reasonably low now the numbers are
going up kim nausea than publishing on
this and Jamie ax and the numbers are
going up but in general it's still a
smaller fraction of the population
because again our population is older
they often don't have computers I've met
veterans that when you say pick up a
mouse they look at the table and like I
don't know what your time up because
this clearly doesn't look like the mouse
you see any mind saying a lot of our
patients don't use an ATM so so these
are barriers that I think will change as
the demographics of our population
changes but that very thing that you're
pointing to it is being done and
actually there has been some preliminary
research published by Steve
science group might believe the Lee
authors haworth NJ mia leone Leone
Hayworth who was his PhD candidate yes
similar question of those two hundred
some-odd veterans that you looked at I'm
curious as to another question well how
many of them go to the same pharmacy for
all the other prescriptions and is there
any way that we can make use of that to
improve our actors go the same pharmacy
for the prescription so okay um yeah I
don't for those so what was the agency
so stepping escaping a step back Cass
can you recall on average what was the
average number of non VA medications
that the patients were taking was it / /
/ around twenty percent okay so twenty
percent okay so on average twenty
percent of the medications that we were
reviewing where medications that were
procured from outside the agency and
that of course they can get from
anywhere over the counters their their
aunts medicine cabinet whatever you know
maybe they're taking their veterinary
meds I don't know but so for those
patients yeah we have no way to actually
link to those those pharmaceutical
repositories it is starting to be done
ken book for the gentleman I was talking
about at the Bronx be he works he's
actually piloting a Rio where they
actually have a network of people that
are doing the pharmaceutical data
exchanges in the in the new year in that
New York borough and they are just
starting to get some preliminary data on
how they actually make argument or
improve the residents ability to collect
a history and validated history when of
patients admitted to the hospital but at
least for our patients we didn't look at
actually where their pharmacy's where
they were procuring from but then on the
flip side eighty percent of them are
getting them from us so and we know
exactly what they're getting they're
getting them all from that same
dispensary yeah James
a related question is the surescripts
database accessible by VA clinicians no
well not yet now I mean unfortunately so
we're still actually we're still trying
to broker the data exchange agreements
and that has to be done the facility
level the provincial level but at the
national level so it may be in some
pilot sites I know as for our site I can
get access only to the data from other
VA's through an essentially an exchange
that's an exchange within the Vista
database that was written for precisely
that purpose we also can get some
information from kaiser we get basically
a stripped or static health summary
exchange from kaiser as part of a
piloting experience there have been
other pilot surprises with DoD there may
be pilots with sure scripts there's
definitely the RIA there's a couple
videos that are done but in terms of
ubiquitous or standardized way to it now
absolutely not and and that's a huge
problem because again the VA I think
James rings a good point to the surface
which is the VA arguably has more
leverage in their court as a federal
organization and yet we haven't done a
lot in that arena to try to actually
standardized normalizer exchange data
with all of our community partners which
is you for example okay well thank you
so much for your time I really
appreciate it was a pleasure and and I
stick around and you guys can always get
it a touch with me were just a sky
bridge away